this weekend
we found like 40 guys coming to be in
the movie I'll I'll work on all the
championship stuff on Monday I'm asking
you to do this now for your mom yes and
I said that I will just not tomorrow
don't be selfish she just lost her
mother
that's more important than your hobby
okay can you stop calling it a hobby
please welcome Gabriel Lavelle
[Music]
it's so nice to meet you
oh my God
[Applause]
um we are both so lucky
um we both have such a amazing
Connection in common that this man
plucked us out of The Ether and changed
our lives yeah what's your experience
with him like it's it's really scary to
to be
representing his life in front of him
every day but he's he's such a as you
know he's I mean he's such a lovely guy
like he's he's really a good person and
I got to know him
um pretty well
um is it true that you would watch him
walk when he was younger yeah so I got
to look at old footage of his family and
and him and
um there's a scene in the movie where he
when he was 16 he made this big war
picture in the desert with his friends
and we kind of recreated that in the
movie and so there's footage of him
walking around like his first big movie
set or his own version of it and he's
very you know like in the late 50s and
60s you tucked your shirt in you comb
your hair your shoulders back chest out
like it's very you're an American man
and you got to be presentable and you
gotta look confident but talking to him
you know he wasn't confident back then
he was very anxious person all of his
energy was in his chest but now 60 years
later and you know he is confident now
and watching him walk from the editing
trailer to set all of his energy it's
not in his chest of where he thinks it
should be but his center of gravity is
lower it's all in his hips and he kind
of like he had any is okay I have to see
this come on okay
Steven Spielberg as a teenager it's kind
of like you know like that I guess it's
very just you know more reserved I guess
shouldered back but then but now like
Steven Spielberg now now he still has
good posture but his head's down and he
always holds a cigar but it's all here
so it's like like he walks slow and and
it's cool
it's it's it's cool it's like an it's
like being in theater camp or something
and you're learning uh you're learning
how to characterize someone by their
walk and it's just cool to kind of
I don't know see what's going on in his
head I guess even though you're being
him what's it like to be directed by him
it's
this big safety net you just feel really
safe as a last question yeah do you know
why he picked you to play himself I
think
in the final callback I had with him I
do the scene and I think it goes really
well but then he asks what's going
through your head and I kind of tell him
what I had prepped and what was and and
it's his emotional scene talking to his
dad and he's getting bullied at school
but it's about like his parents
splitting up and and I kind of go over
it and
after after I say that and he's like you
nailed the Gestalt of the divorce
perfectly and we were able to uh I don't
know I think I think we connected on
that I think I just
honestly I don't know that's me assuming
and your parents had gotten divorced too
mine were separated before I was born
his parents got divorced it's just an
incredible movie you're amazing thank
you I'm so happy to meet I'm driving to
you too I love
and congratulations on all the critical
Acclaim thank you so much is being
warranted we'll be right back
[Music]